welcome to Simon dev in this JavaScript
tutorial we're going to be exploring
implementing minecraft whoo
pretty sure you all know what minecraft
is even if you haven't played it it was
developed about nine years ago by a
company called Mojang and went on to
become one of the biggest games of all
time the game itself is relatively
simple you have this procedural blocky
world that you can interact with in a
variety of ways you can alter and modify
the world excavating out areas building
massive structures that sort of thing
the world is procedurally generated with
forests lakes oceans Tundra different
climates and biomes reflecting the
variety in the world
we used 3GS just to get a basic renderer
up but everything here is mostly written
from scratch
the code is all available on github so
take a look if you're interested the
link is in the description below and if
anything doesn't makes any sense feel
free to comment below what we're going
to go over today I'll show you how we go
from I want to make minecraft to a
complete working world I'll go over what
I was thinking how I planned this out
and what mistakes I made along the way
alright so let's dig in and build this
things from scratch shall we so
minecraft is graphically at least a
simple game there's not a whole hell of
a lot going on this super complex it's a
super boxy environment so the first
thing we need to do is get a box drawing
up on the screen now getting a box up on
the screen isn't hard the challenge
comes from getting more boxes on the
screen you can see here that we can draw
a single box just fine framerate is good
but as we add more boxes we can we can
tank the framerate pretty easily so we
we had a few thousand or tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
boxes then the framework will sync even
with the best GPU one of the first
things I thought about was how to render
the world if you architected the code
well right from the beginning you might
be able to just get away with a super
slow drawing method where each
individual Vox who was drawn every frame
and then drop in a replacement later as
it reaches its limits but I was pretty
sure that we'd hit some framerate limit
really quickly and so I started to think
about how to draw this
there's a bunch of ideas I had floating
around in this area that could all
potentially speed things up with varying
degrees of complexity you could stitch
together meshes and cache and rebuild
them as necessary you could use instance
thing to do something similar by
offloading some of the work to the
rendering pipeline you could use planes
or cubes for finer or coarser control
you could atlas the textures together to
reduce trial calls and merge meshes etc
since I wanted to get something working
that was somewhat performant but I
didn't want to do a ton of work I chose
to just use instancing with cubes
alright so that gives us the beginnings
of a working world it's big enough but
there's a bunch of things we need to do
I'll just go ahead and add some small
touches here so that this looks a little
bit more like a world what I've done is
gone and added a skybox and just some
white cubes in the sky they're randomly
placed up high and I threw a whitish
texture on them now first alpha if I
move to the end of the world I'll just
fall off that's a problem so we need to
make this whole world continuous one
easy way is to chunk up the world into
squares for the sake of simplicity
imagine the visible world is nine
squares with you being at the center as
you move in one direction and change
from being in the center Square to one
of the outer squares what we do is throw
away the old squares they're too far
away and generate new squares just for
the ones that came into view see here
I'm just moving towards the horizon and
now the land is popping into existence
as we move giving us an infinite world
effect now we're getting somewhere
the next thing I did was start looking
into adding the actual interaction with
the world minecraft is a Minecraft II
because you can dig remove add crap that
kind of thing so we need to be able to
do the same thing we can break this up
into two actions there's some
similarities between them first up
deleting voxels from the world the way I
chose to do this was the easiest way I
could think of which is to basically
draw a line right from the camera
straight ahead and find the first cube
that intersects with that line this is
just a ray cube intersection test which
is a couple lines of code and most
libraries already implemented
for you three Jas happens to have one
already so we just used that once you
have the cube that directly in front of
you all you need to do is hide it in our
case I just set the visible flag to
false and then mark this section of the
world as needing to be rebuilt and voila
it's gone
I'll go walk around a bit and delete a
few more but that's all there is to it I
cast a ray in the direction I'm looking
at and check all the voxels nearby find
the closest one and then hide it that's
it so let's move on to adding blocks to
the world adding blocks is a bit more
complex but not noticeably so we do the
exact same thing we did for delete in
that we cast array forward and trying to
find the closest voxel but instead of
deleting it what I'm gonna do is look
directly above it and see if there's
anything there if there's another voxel
above it we don't do anything but if
there's a free space above it then we'll
insert one into the world so once you
have that closest cube you check above
it and then you insert a new cube into
the world and tell the section of the
world to be rebuilt again and voila your
new block appears I'll walk around a bit
and throw down a bunch more of these
blocks now I could have gotten a more
complex implementation let you build
blocks on the side of other blocks or
something like that but we're just
keeping this super simple so you can
build up but to build side-by-side you
need to build everywhere and then delete
the ones you don't want so we have some
problems with our implementation right
now one being that if I dig down for
example there's nothing underneath it's
just a void if we remove a few blocks
and then jump in we kind of fall into
the nothingness now since I don't want
to just fall forever I added a safety
net in the camera code that says if I
fall far enough we were set above the
land so here I remove a bunch of blocks
and then jump in and fall through the
world without the safety net I'll just
fall forever so I reset the camera
position to above the world and then we
fall from up there and eventually hope
do we make our way back to the land
anyway the point is I don't think we
want these voids in our world where you
can fall into an eternity of nothing so
let's fix that there's a couple ways you
could do this each with their own
trade offs an easy possible way is to
just pre generate the land to a certain
depth here I pre generated it to two
voxel steep and of course we could make
a ten or twenty or a hundred or a
thousand it doesn't matter one problem
is that you need a smarter a renderer in
place we do this because all of those
voxels are potentially chewing up GPU
time even though they're not visible and
just getting discarded they still have
to flow through the GPU and waste shader
time before getting depth tested out
ideally we need to have a better way to
do this that doesn't rely on the GPU to
cut all of this for us another problem
is that I can still dig through the
world it just takes a bit longer now
maybe minecraft allows this or it
doesn't or to have some sort of
impassable layer at some point now what
I did was when you remove a voxel I
check around underneath it and I just
add new voxels in so it doesn't matter
how far you dig will just keep adding
stuff see so now when you dig you can
dig as far as you want there's no bottom
I could technically put in a restriction
of how far down you can go but I didn't
the only limit is wherever we blow out
memory so digging and adding voxels
roughly works the next thing I did was
try to make the world a little bit more
interesting right now we have an
infinite plane of grass in all
directions but Minecrafts world has
hills oceans mountains that kind of
stuff a good starting place to look for
this kind of procedural generation is
purlins or simplex noise if you're not
familiar with those they're just a way
of getting a multi dimensional
continuous randomness if that's a bit
confusing think of it like this you can
randomly choose values let's say I
randomly at every box we'll choose a
height but there's no continuity here
it's not continuous meaning it doesn't
gradually go from one value to the next
it's totally random each voxel cell now
imagine instead I decide to choose one
single random height every 50 voxels or
so and between them I just blend it
would look something like this
see how it's more continuous it slopes
gently up from each random point this is
in super hand-wavy terms what purlins or
simplex noise gives you they give you
continuous
multi-dimensional noise which is great
for a procedural world because you can
have gently sloping hills and valleys
and that kind of thing
now that the noise is integrated into
the world you can also run it through a
bunch of different filters layered on
top of itself a few times run it through
magical functions to get different
effects but the gist of it is this
sampling a continuous noise function to
build out the procedural world a bit we
can keep going down this road quite a
bit more making the procedural world
much more complex and realistic but for
part 1 of this video I'm stopping at
Hills well we'll do next though is add
some different biomes to the world just
to show how it's done
first up whenever the land is super low
we'll consider that to be ocean that is
whenever the height of the ground is
less than some threshold we'll consider
that to be water area and close to the
water
we'll stop using the grass tiles and
we'll start using sand tiles which will
give us a bunch of beaches you can see
that we've got beaches here and you can
of course dig and do whatever else you
want here just like you could with the
grass the water will need to be a bit
special and what we'll do here is
instead of the cubes we've been using
will use a single plane throw a
semi-transparent water texture owner and
then he voxels that are on the surface
of the water we use this instead it's
kind of looking waterish pretty decent
stuff and walk on it which isn't right
but I'll add some swimming or whatever
in a later update but we have oceans
which is awesome starting to look kind
of cool since this is just part 1 and I
intend to follow up here I'm not going
to go nuts and keep adding stuff the
last big thing I'll add here is trees
which gives some character to the
landscape now trees are just voxels like
everything else we just need to decide
two things where to put them and what
shape to make them shape is easy
we need a trunk which consists of a
couple of ox holes in the line and then
what I'll try and do is copy the
pictures of trees I saw in Minecraft the
leaves kind of look like a box with the
corners missing and they're often 2
layers so I'll just do the same thing
and it ends up looking like this see the
trunk is just a couple log voxels and I
can even chop it and you can see inside
and see the Rings to the tree and the
leaves are of course box
as well which means I can go ahead and
remove these if I want to and reshape
this entire thing or delete it
completely
finally there's two last touches that I
want to add to make this all look a bit
nicer and that is distance fog and tone
mapping see when we walk around the
world just kind of pops into view
abruptly which isn't cool I mean it
works but it would be nicer if it just
kinda came in smoothly and you didn't
notice it and we can use distance fog to
do that all we're gonna do is the
further something is away we'll blend
the color between that and the color of
the sky see here in this example I've
expanded the world considerably it's a
lot bigger now but the edge is pretty
much covered by this distance fog and
blends into the sky seamlessly if I turn
the effect off everything pops back into
view and stands out and so as I move
towards the horizon you can see trees
popping in and out which isn't visually
appealing so we turn the fog back on and
as you move nothing pops into existence
anymore I'm also gonna add a tone
mapping operator here which I just
bolted right into the fragment shader I
can do a tutorial and tone mapping if
anybody is interested but it's
essentially a way of mapping HDR or high
dynamic range to ldr or low dynamic
range range being the range of colors
and your monitor being the one with the
more limited range so it's starting to
look pretty decent nice and bright and
nothing is super washed out or
overexposed I'm also going to break up
the monotony of the landscape by varying
the color from one voxel to the next
what we'll do is define a valid range of
colors for each biome and randomly
choose something from within that range
that way we get a bit more break up in
the pattern otherwise you have this
perfectly identical pattern across the
landscape that just looks a bit boring
I think the Minecraft Wiki lists the
different colors for each biome so I'll
read that in the future to get some
better variation what I'm doing here is
just playing with the luminance a bit
varying it by a few percent we could
just flat-out use randomness here but
I'm using a secondary noise calculation
to vary it continuously across the
landscape and I feel it comes out pretty
decent
that about wraps up part 1 of this I
showed you how to go essentially from a
single cube on the screen to getting an
entire voxel world up and running and it
expands infinitely in every direction
you can move as far as you want it
doesn't matter
we'll just keep generating more terrain
we added interactivity to it and a few
basic biomes and plants in future
updates if there's interest I can add
better shading to the voxels better
procedural generation for the world more
biomes multiplayer support to make this
into a much more complete and
functioning minecraft clone for now I
hope this was easy enough to follow and
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more like it give it a like and hit
that subscribe button in the corner also
let me know what you'd like to see in
the future if you have ideas for future
videos leave a comment below until next
time cheers everyone